[Music]
homie look what I become
hello hello okay so what do we got today
we got podcast episode 251 home team
um we got some crazy things going on we
had our notes ready yes ready to go Tom
printed a couple you had to use a couple
trees to get get his notes ready and
what he's got to talk about down with
trees right right and then all of a
sudden obviously a tragic tragic event
takes place yesterday taking the lives
of three people
uh this transgender who uh uh depending
on what article you read is going to
tell you different stories of a man a
woman she walks in there's videos of it
now that you can see takes the lives of
three nine-year-olds innocent
nine-year-olds two 61 year olds and I
believe one the head of the school and
she had a Manifesto we'll talk about it
today on the podcast obviously we got a
lot of other stories that are also
business issues but we'll definitely get
into this uh I know
uh uh the the last thing I have some
friends in Nashville I texted I called
them you guys good you guys everybody's
good your body's good but you know there
are six families right now that are
dealing with this and our condolences
goes out to their entire family to hear
a another tragic event like this we'll
talk about it but there's a couple other
things we got to talk about business
Tick Tock Tom's got got some thoughts on
Tick Tock issues that's taking place
there's a Wall Street Journal story that
I saw I think all of you would enjoy
this story it gives such insight about
what's happened to American values the
article reads America pulls back from
values that once defined it if you see
how dramatically our values have changed
from 1998 which you and I in 1998 were
how old in our 20s maybe right not even
20s 17 17 you were 16. weren't you like
1990 it's just yeah so to where we are
today it it's telling where we're at
um there's an incident on what happened
with the chat gbt that saved the dog's
life very interesting what direction
some people are going to be getting
doctors advice from chat gbt Tom's got
thoughts on AOC uh events that is taking
place with Netanyahu I know you got some
thoughts on that as well and Vinnie on
the the scientists where Trump told the
census he came in tears he was crying
maybe we can talk about the conversation
where Trump told Hannity yesterday how
DeSantis came in tears begging for with
tissues for his endorsement now having
said that gank
um here's what's going to be at the uh a
live podcast that we're doing uh next is
it next Thursday right it's next
Thursday April 6th here's who it's going
to be confirmed in the uh flesh with us
it'll be Dave Rubin who will be in the
podcast uh with us live at the 5990
building as well as a man named Rudy
Giuliani and to say it's going to be a
very interesting one if you want to pick
up tickets and register there's a few
tickets left the VIP is definitely sold
out text award uh uh podcast to
310-340-1132-340-310-340-1132 text award
podcast
and we will send you the link you can
even go to
5990live.com to get registered again
59.99
59.90 live.com if you can put the link
below as well Robert so people can get
it go get your tickets I think we got 28
tickets left or 27 tickets left uh it'll
sell out uh the last one we did was an
incredible event obviously you know
there's a part of Dave that's going to
defend on the DeSantis side lean a
little bit more on the descentesis
although he's supportive of trump as
well and we know where uh mayor
giuliani's gonna lean but at the timely
the amount of things to talk about with
all these investigations this is a man
that's been through it for many many
years there isn't someone that's got as
much experience to talk talk about this
as he does on Trump on tick tock on
Hunter Biden on a bunch of different
things that's going on and we're coming
to you at a very special time it's going
to be 6 p.m that we're live I think it's
6 p.m people come in but we'll be going
seven to nine and then afterwards
everybody will be hanging out together
some of the guys that are VIP will go to
the Cigar Lounge we'll have a cigar
together a nighttime party I've never
done this before this will be the first
night time we're doing because it's the
weekend of UFC so some people can come
enjoy South Florida and go watch the UFC
fight on Saturday anyway having said
that let's get maybe you should have
Dave Rubin fight Rudy Giuliani yeah
let's get let's watch that let's get
right we got my money on Reuben
obviously have a weight class problem
there obviously we're going to talk
about what happened with Nashville let
me just go into a couple different
stories here and then we'll get into
that as well Michael Jordan picks
perfect time to sell the Hornets okay
it's the perfect time to sell the
Hornets Tom this is something you have
some strong opinions on but let me just
read the article first so Michael Jordan
is selling his majority stick of
Charlotte Hornets which he bought in uh
for 275 million dollars in 2010 a
reported 1.7 billion dollars this would
mean a significant profit for Jordan
whose tenure as majority owner saw the
team uh reached only the playoff Birds
two times and no second round of the
postseason the bankruptcy of teams local
media partner Diamond Sports Group could
put the future meteorites of 42. listen
to this folks MLB NHL and NBA's teams in
Jeopardy representing an existential
threat to the League's teams like the
Hornets whose games are aired on Valley
Sports Southeast rely heavy on the cable
and then be attributed 13 of last
season's earnings to local media deals
Jordan may be looking to downsize his
ownership role due to struggles as an
owner and instead to focus on other
Ventures such as his Nike brand or his
new NASCAR team a deal is not imminent
but if he decides to move on he may not
find a better opportunity Tom well I
think a buyer is also going to find an
opportunity here and what has happened
these local sportsnets Valley Sports if
you Google that you see what happened to
them that is critical I I've been
reading it's anywhere from 13 to 20
percent depending on the team so in
other words if you're the owner and you
suddenly lose 13 to 20 percent of you
know what's coming in you're gonna have
to reach into your pocket next year and
cover the difference because you've got
existing player contracts you've got
existing leases on your stadium so
Jordan's in a good place because he
bought it such a compelling price and
the franchise is worth 1.7 so even if
someone came along and said yeah I'm
only going to pay you one three one four
or some number he could still make a
good a tremendous deal on it and someone
is still going to get a deal on the team
but that someone is still gonna have to
figure out the gap on these local sports
it's happening all over baseball and
it's happening here this is just where
the the economics of the time in which
we live these um Regional Sports Nets
even with great advertising you get more
advertising for live of programming
because people don't fast forward
through it and they don't like you know
watch it on DVR later and then skip so
all that's coming home here but this
could be a win for Michael Jordan but
also a win for someone that wants to get
in as an NBA owner because I don't think
they're going to pay the price that's in
Forbes because what just happened with
the regional Sports Group that's going
to be a discount effect I'm gonna take a
different angle you talk about a win
from Michael Jordan uh MJ needs a win at
this point in his career because there's
no question he is the goat greatest of
all time NBA you can whoever you want to
put second third fourth fifth you want
to put LeBron you want to put Kobe you
want to put Bill Russell Wilt
Chamberlain throw them on unless it's
all good MJ's number one but on the list
of all-time worst owners in NBA history
MJ's on Goat Mountain it's been so nice
of Donald Sterling uh worse than Phoenix
listen Goat Mountain yes Phoenix has
been to the finals before MJ how many
times has he even been to the playoffs
well that's one team the Phoenix owner
has proved to be a pig
the reality is this uh what we've
realized with MJ is that as great as you
are as a player it doesn't mean anything
as an owner or general manager listen
I'm a huge Miami Heat fan I've been to a
million games season tickets
um we've won multiple championships with
the Heat Dwyane Wade Shaq the whole
Squad everything that we've done over
here when we see Charlotte Hornets who's
in our division show up on the calendar
it's like just throw a w right there
because this team doesn't do [__] and
you would assume that if MJ is the owner
of your team
there's going to be some MJ magic you're
gonna maybe make it to the playoffs
you're gonna make a run nothing the only
thing they have to speak of is they have
lamelo ball who again broke his ankle
this year yeah so talk about breaking
ankles in the NBA it's just I'm an MJ
fan I mean I'm a Isaiah Thomas fan to be
honest with you Pistons Bad Boys but I
want to see MJ succeed as an owner I
want to see his team do well
unfortunately they're just trash so why
don't you Adam what would be the the
reason and you think behind somebody
with that much knowledge for the game
that much power that many relationships
that he can't turn a team like that
around
why do you think that yeah I'm curious I
don't know I think it's a combination of
factors I think they haven't had a good
coach in years I think the general
manager hasn't done much I think the
draft picks have turned out turned out
well other than lamello I think the best
player they've had in the last 10 years
has been Kemba Walker he's out of the
league at this point but they had a
Mecca Okafor I just they they have not
put together a good squad and I wonder
why I think it's an opportunity
um I'm sorry Pat no no go ahead I think
it's an opportunity that is why if I was
in Charlotte first of all North Carolina
is like basket Indiana and North
Carolina and Kansas is like the two most
natural basketball states of the nation
you have Duke you have UNC Chapel Hill
you have NC State and the legend of
Jimmy Valvano you have Wake Forest uh
Tim Duncan went to Wake Forest I think I
believe yeah so you you have this in
this basketball crazy State that's
crying for an owner that cares enough to
reverse everything that you just
correctly pointed out the checklist you
just gave I agree with but I think
there's an opportunity for someone to do
it and Charlotte although is the second
capital of the U.S banking industry as
we know it's known as the second capital
you would think there'd be some money
there but banking's got a little here's
what's going on here's what I would say
wise move because MBA is a shitty
product today and take your 1.7 billion
go put it elsewhere you're going to get
better returns than leaving it in the
NBA do I think the NBA franchise you
know is it going to double in the next
decade yeah is it going to get seven to
seven point two percent over the next
decade maybe who knows but maybe he can
he's going to get 7.2 percent the other
part is you know to to choose to be an
owner it's a different it's a it's a
very different philosophy to be an owner
than it is to be a GM than it is to be a
coach than it is to be a superstar than
it is to be a benchwarmer the same
mindset doesn't work when you're owning
a team when you're owning a team it
can't be about the owner it has to be
about the player it's a very very
different Dynamic when you're wanting to
go that route anyway eventually it needs
to be more about somebody else that
hasn't happened here yet but if you're
buying a sports team today I don't know
if I'm buying an NBA team it's a waste
of time to go to see any father that's
thinking about spending a thousand
dollars to take his son to watch LeBron
play to watch uh Curry play to watch you
know anybody play except for a couple
players that won't miss a game anybody
that's thinking about spending a
thousand dollars there is a high
likelihood that your favorite player may
not play on that day why the hell would
you take your kid with a thousand
dollars that you have to go watch the
game knowing the best player may not
play in a season game it's a shitty
product today there's better products
than the NBA to consider playoffs
different story but season I think NBA's
a is not a good product today anyways
let's go to the next one so
Tom Tick Tock is what I'm going to next
AOC Tick Tock defense ripped after
Chinese parent company gave six figure
donations to Hispanic caucus non-profits
having to do with uh AOC and let's see
how AOC is tied to this because she did
a video that everybody was talking about
but it wasn't all the good things that
was talked about her so here we go AOC
defended Tick Tock after they revealed
that the Chinese owned parent company
bike that's donated six-figure
contribution to non-profit aligned with
Congressional Black and Hispanic
caucuses including the Congressional
Black Caucus foundation and
Congressional Hispanic caucus uh
foundation in her defense of tick tock
AOC argued that Congress should focus on
regulating social media companies
unchecked habit of collecting user data
without their consent instead of banning
an individual company she also called
for Congress to use to receive a
classified briefing before proposing to
ban and for the public to be informed
about the justification for such a
decision Tom what is going on here with
Tick Tock and AOC Tick Tock is playing
the game that Facebook and everybody
else has played and it's called make
sure you make donations to the people
that may need to help you if you get
your butt hauled before Congress for a
hearing there's no difference in what
Tick Tock is doing with a lot of uh
pharmaceutical companies and others do
in the United States and AOC who's the
anti-viagra for half of America you know
she's out there touting that by the way
just so you know a lot of people would
disagree with you oh yeah what do you
mean a lot of people with this a lot of
people for two minutes would be willing
to set politics aside but go ahead yeah
if it was me I'd have to be please don't
talk
um
[Laughter]
so what AOC was doing she was preaching
to the donation there's preaching to the
choir but there's also preaching to the
donation she was preaching to the
donation the other part of this it was
very interesting it gets worse that the
cyber security lawyer for tick tock who
is scolding us about the hearings
was Dandy West who formerly works for
the office of the Director of National
Intelligence so you had a former lawyer
that worked for the United States
Director of National Intelligence leaves
government and does what a lot of people
in government too you go work for the
private sector we've talked about so
many people in defense that go get on
the boards of defense companies well
Dandy West d-o-n-d-i-s formerly worked
for the office of Director of National
Intelligence and she's out there now as
a cyber security lawyer for tick tock
blasting the United States and lecturing
us where she got her education and
worked in our government so did you
watch any of the hearings back and forth
what do you thought yeah so well I think
it's important to find out I mean the
the AOC story is just
uh drop in the bucket of what's really
happening right now so last week the CEO
of tick tock his name is Shu zi Chu he's
a 40 year old
um he's actually born in Singapore was
went to school in London uh worked for
Goldman Sachs actually went to Harvard
to get his
um MBA so he's sort of been all around
the block he came and sat down in front
of Congress if there's one thing that I
can appreciate what's happening in
Congress right now is the lack of
bipartisanship when it comes to tick
tock Democrats and Republicans both
scolded Mr Chu about basically what's
happening with Tick Tock indoctrinating
our youth we've talked about this before
if you look at Tick Tock in China it's
all things to educate the youth math
science Humanities whatever they're
allowed to show in China whereas here
it's just nonsense dances you know
Clorox bleach challenges on steroids and
and I think you know Tick Tock has
already been banned in what India a
couple couple times major countries yeah
a lot of
um countries in the EU banned it from
government I think the United States is
actually already banned it from
government phones government buildings
exactly right you know
um
this essentially is a trojan horse for
China to indoctrinate American Youth and
I think it should be a concern now if
you ask the average 16 year old what
they think about Tick Tock they love
Tick Tock but uh fortunately 16 year
olds aren't making the decisions in this
country right now and you made a great
I'm sorry I didn't go um you made a
great point about the Trojan Horse we
were talking about before we walked in
here for my my one first thing is every
week it seems like there's another story
of China and how they're trying to screw
us okay if you go back from think about
it covet pandemic shut down the world
China okay they're flying spy balloons
Over America nobody gives a damn it took
all its photos always shot it over the
water like you said about Tick Tock
they're indoctrinating the children
they're finding out who are the Smart
Ones how coordinated they are the dumb
ones that are going to drink the bleach
and when are we going to save is enough
is enough I know we owe them a shitload
of money but who's gonna step up the
only person that did Step Up was Trump
and they crucified them because they
called them racist for just saying hold
them accountable make them pay their
[__] fair share in in trade and then
look what happens a pandemic comes out
from over there and and he's bye-bye so
the hypocrisy here is amazing so take a
look at this not only well they're
playing the political game well and
they're getting a lobbyist in there and
they're doing all that and then aoc's
out there saying oh it's a slippery
slope if you ban an app really you
wanted to ban Trump social you wanted to
ban parlor so now it's okay to ban this
one so that's a little hypocrisy but the
hypocrisy goes deeper let's look at
China in the hypocrisy this is a list of
American technology companies that are
banned from the citizenry of central
China Facebook Instagram WhatsApp Google
YouTube Bing Twitter Snapchat Reddit
Tumblr Pinterest slack twitch Discord
Dropbox quora medium Wikipedia Vimeo
Flickr SoundCloud and duckduck
goal has to be on there so that
amazingly enough PornHub is not
mentioned but by the way by the way what
you just said is very powerful yes very
powerful now we're racist yeah exactly
so you what what is it with so was that
question even asked that see that's the
part that that question wasn't asked
though so what makes you think you can
ban those apps in China but us choosing
to ban you in the country is you know
biggest you know whatever you want to
call this other stuff by the way
phenomenal take there Tom can you do me
a favor I got three Clips I want to show
you guys from this if you haven't seen
it one is from New York Times one is
from Kirk which I think Kirk's gonna be
on the podcast in a week or two and the
other one is from Bloomberg can you get
those three Clips ready uh Rob start off
with the first one New York Times let's
go there first and see this is a
democratic uh I believe congresswoman
questioning Kim and look how this thing
goes it's 50 seconds
opening statement about a firewall
relative you raise the volume a little
bit
the Chinese government has that Dash
how can you promise that that that will
move into uh into the United States of
America and be protected here
congresswoman I have seen no evidence
that the Chinese government has access
to that data they have never asked us we
have not provided well you know what
I've asked that I find that actually
Preposterous I have uh there's been I
have seen no evidence of this happening
and in order to assure everybody here
and all our users our commitment is to
move the data in into the United States
to be stored on American soil by an
American company overseen by American
Personnel so the risk will be similar to
any government going to an American
company asking for data there you go but
with that congresswoman Vinnie just
asked me she is serious she's a Syrian
California wow Syrian play the other one
play the one with Charlie crook watch
this one this one's got five million
views
my colleague representative Latta
confirmed that your parent company by
dance currently can access user data yes
let's uh we have to be more specific
um yes after project Texas no I'm not
asking after project Texas I'm asking
now yes some user data is public data
congresswoman which means everybody can
my colleague representative answered
that right now go to the last one with
Bloomberg this next one is the Wi-Fi one
which is what this is this is where we
remember how Tom asked the question Adam
said they can't use tick tock in the
government buildings and you know
government phones and he said Wi-Fi he
says you can't use it there they have
the ability apparently through your
Wi-Fi to see all the other things you're
doing on your phone if tiktok play this
clip Jesus Christ Mr Chew does tick tock
access the home Wi-Fi network
only if the user turns on the Wi-Fi I'm
sorry I may not understand that so if I
have a stick talk app on my phone and my
phone is on my home Wi-Fi network does
tick tock access that Network
it will have to to access the network to
get connections to the internet if
that's the question is it possible then
that it could access other devices on
that home Wi-Fi network
Congressman that we do not do anything
that is beyond any industry Norms
um I believe the answer to the question
is no it could be technical let me get
back to you but I appreciate it if you
can answer it
the professional [__] just keep
playing it look at the guy sitting next
to him by the way that's the guy I'm
interested in when you pause it who's
the guy sitting right next to him to his
right lawyers now press play again for
for the eyes you got to see the eyes
he's got the eye look at that yeah
that's a legit La Costa no strap hey
don't say nothing who do you think he is
right there I mean I just think it's
important to point out that
um we'll State the obvious here bite
dance is the owner of tick tock bite
Tans what percentage of the CCP owns
bite dance the a decent percentage of it
like meaning the CCP does have ownership
in it and I think we're talking about
this question of data and privacy and
spying and you know called me an
old-fashioned red-blooded American yeah
but if any tech company is going to be
spying on me I wanted to be an American
family I wanted to be tell them I wanted
to be Instagram I want it to be Google
yeah I wanted to be YouTube I want
American-owned companies I agree to be
looking at my dad and inspiring on me
like a good old-fashioned American not
no Chinese company American okay America
First yeah and Exxon tried that if it
wasn't for the Valdez those Ducks could
be covered with foreign oil that's right
but it's it's actually an interesting
Brandon that you make isn't it isn't it
crazy how far we've gotten like wasn't
during all the surveillance during Obama
people Americans were up in arms right
people were like I can't believe they're
taking it and that look at how amazing
and Brilliant from Mark Zuckerberg to
tick tock to all this social media now
it they made it cool for you back in the
day if somebody saw your any I was like
oh I don't want people now it's like for
instance my sister's huge if you don't
know nothing about my sister you go on
her Facebook you know what she does
where she eats what she's doing what
music she loves who she hates her
political thing dude you know everything
like the CIA I heard they have a name
for Mark Zuckerberg like they love him
because what what surveil you for what
go on two social media apps I know
everything about you I know where you're
gonna go next they have that type of
Technology where they're like well we've
monitored you for the past three days we
know that because of your pattern you're
gonna go to this restaurant on this day
at this time yeah think about it that
was cool white man has acquired a
percent stake in one of three sets of
board of Beijing by dance technology the
subsidiary that holds license that
underpin the company's domestic video
and information sharing platforms
according to a person family no matter
who spoke to another very interesting
yeah
and just think about it the um when you
go and you download any of these apps
right I'm joking about red-blooded
Americans like um
data is money at this point yeah
eyeballs are money when you go and you
download into these apps American-owned
apps you know they give you the whole
10 Page Long disclosure uh table of
contents of what's gonna happen all you
do is scroll down to the bottom except
100 keep it moving let me just get the
app yeah so who knows what kind of [__]
is said there yeah when you're basically
downloading these apps yeah so nobody's
reading that stuff like we're gonna take
your firstborn child yeah okay this I
want to get ready spying on you left and
right do you agree I agree yeah let's
get I want to see those dancing and now
when you find out people don't have
Instagram and Facebook aren't you like
what the hell is wrong with you you
almost get mad at them because they're
not giving out information the way that
you you know and so much of this has
come full circle who did AOC defeat when
she became House Representatives Amazon
Joe Crowley Joe Crowley for the last two
years being that he lost his old job
because she beat him is a paid lobbyist
that works directly for tick tock so
isn't it interesting
that suddenly the guy she defeated in
her finally on the same side of an issue
they're both trying to protect Tick-Tock
but this the circles that have come
around on this are just so ironic even
could you say that and we follow the
money and you think about it I don't the
term selling your soul was like well if
you pay me enough money I questions this
weekend when I was out at lunch with
friends how much money would it take for
somebody to give you like listen shut up
I know we're taking all the data from
your own citizens and you're in Congress
take this million cash shut the hell up
I may ask you the the whole
uh example you did when you were when
you you were posting on Tick Tock you
were getting like four views and then
you called China out or bite dense out
and then you got four million views
where do you stand now give us that
rundown oh yeah it that's uh absolutely
proven on what happens with that we saw
the videos are back to normal but if you
look at my Instagram if you look at my
Tick Tock profile today I posted a video
of Joe talking about our our podcast and
how we do interviews and and I posted
that that got flagged they said that is
a a warning for the content and then I
got a warning sign on my Tick Tock
account and uh uh uh multiple whatever
way now now there's a new thing that
they're talking about strikes and uh but
it's back to normal what it was before
again but I have if you say anything
about China on Tick Tock you're gonna
get flagged what if it's a bunch of
pictures of she and you're like I love
him like what if you're supporting him
by the way do you know what's the one
video that went viral on Tick Tock
yesterday a girl talking about why uh
politicians are afraid of tick tock and
they want to ban it he says she says you
want to ban Tick Tock because we're
getting smarter because we're getting
stronger than you because us young
teenagers and yeah we're getting this
and we're getting that that's why that
video went weird viral dude calling out
you know all this stuff not knowing
what's really going on anyways let's go
to the next story Adam I know you got
some opinions on this one here is this
the end of male over achievers love
affair would work a Bloomberg story in
the U.S corporate life
and the U.S corporate life is defined by
overwork and its reverence first of all
nobody says that but that's what
Bloomberg says what higher up expected
to work longer hours and receive high
rewards for men tend to end up at the
top of professionals that are most
demanding and lucrative while women get
shut out due to sexism just reading this
article is due to sexism and not having
enough time to dedicate to these types
of jobs which result in top earning men
making more than top earning women
evidence shows that pandemic may have
disrupted corporate American America's
love affair with workaholism between
2019 and 2022 men who were the biggest
earners and our clockers cut back on
work more than any other cohort how many
other cohorts are there it's men and
women that's it the average U.S worker
locked 1791 hours in 2021 Which is
higher than other countries such as
Canada Japan UK France and Germany
overwork
exasperated the gender gap by 10 but the
pandemic may have delivered the shock
needed to push that Trend into reverse
so cohort they're talking other
countries So Adam what are your thoughts
on this so I I mean this as I'm reading
this I'm kind of like throwing up in my
mouth a little bit right there just it's
just so far-fetched and so ridiculous so
it's
it's basically saying women are getting
shut out of the workplace because of
sexism I mean I probably get canceled
for saying this but if you go just to
human nature and human evolution
men were born to work and this used to
be known as hunter-gatherers right men
with Hunters women were the gatherers
men were men were out there killing the
saber-toothed tigers and woolly mammoths
and risking their life to put food on
the table for their family whereas the
the mothers were raising the children
and creating homes and only in the last
30 40 years with modern feminism has
this has this sort of been questioned
and women work all you want please but
part of the reason that you're talking
about sexism and not having enough time
that it's women have what are those
things that that women typically have
when they get pregnant oh babies a lot
of times when they have babies they they
don't work for a good year two three
four or five years
whereas the man continues to work men
were built to work if you see a man out
there who doesn't work he's like yeah
I'm just not feeling the work thing
right now just like what are you what
are you talking about yeah that's an
unacceptable thing to say as a man 100
as a woman if you're like well I'm not
really working right now I'm a maternity
leave my husband totally understand
where you're coming from and at the end
of the day for a man we have this debate
over work-life balance 40 around 40 hour
work weeks your input is equal to your
output what you put in is what you'll
get out if you want to work the bare
minimum just expect the bare minimum if
you want to put in long hours and work
your ass off and build something and
create something and consistently
improve you'll get out what you put into
it so at the end of the day when it
comes to investing it's risk and reward
yeah you're willing to risk it all
what's the reward by the way when you're
saying maternity leave one year two
years three years five years it's 12
weeks in America you're saying that some
choose to go spend that time with their
kid with their babies what you're
talking correct yeah the most part
maternity leave is typically I'm not
saying four weeks accordingly just to
clarify I'm not talking about corporate
you know allotted time I'm saying a lot
of women are saying I'm not even going
back to work right for a year right yeah
and that's why I brought up Pete Buddha
judge because I mean he's out back at
work but he's not really working
well he's just whatever I don't agree
with him taking off months three months
or however long anyway Pat what's your
thoughts on this one right here since
you're a male overachiever
yeah well do the opposite see what
happens to you go ahead yeah do the
opposite go be a male underachiever see
how you feel about yourself why don't we
hey Bloomberg why don't we have more
male Underachievers according to the way
you're judging male overachievers what
do you think will happen to society if
we increase male Underachievers yeah
okay more male Underachievers they tend
to nothing highly of themselves they
tend to not get girls they tend to not
have their dreams become a reality and
they tend to become a menace to society
they ruin things in society when they
become Underachievers Underachievers are
not good for society and Bloomberg is
sitting here bashing overachievers let
me ask you a question when you celebrate
Daniel Day Lewis winning how many
different Awards he's won the most
Oscars I believe for what is it uh
leading the Mohicans uh last of the
movies my left foot my left foot these
one three or four of them right Oscars
he went out there and lived in the woods
to know what it feels like like so he
didn't act he lived it right what an
overachiever terrible guy right oh my
horrible guy on when when Johnny Depp
goes and plays Pirates of the Caribbean
and he does such a good job that now
Disney has to offer him 301 million
dollars and he's still not going to go
back what an overachiever or
underachiever guy what a bad thing he is
to society one of Michael Jordan goals
practices or Kobe goes practices what
what a terrible overachiever we got if
there's anything we need in America it's
not more Underachievers God knows we
need moral Achievers so overachievers
out there we salute you keep kicking ass
we recognize you for your efforts for
your sacrifice because it's a lot of
work and FYI to me overachievers is not
just in work I see mothers who go above
and beyond for their kids who are
overachievers I see CEOs I see sales
people I see customer service I see a
person that works at McDonald's that's
an overachiever I salute you I don't
care what your job is if you're going
above and beyond to do your job
eventually someone's going to take
notice and you're going to get a
promotion one of the best stories Ron
Paul ever told me was the following
Ron Paul said I got addicted to this one
Economist and I would go drive up this
guy was a he gave I don't know 4 000
deliveries of babies what Ron Paul's
done he says so all of a sudden I'm
starting reading these economy books and
I'm addicted I can't stop reading so I
go back to the lecture and I said look I
can't stop reading this stuff what do I
do with all this material I'm learning
about he says let me tell you how the
world works you keep talking about what
you believe in the right people will
show up and figure out a way to use you
effectively so if you are at any company
doing anything you can if you're an
overachiever don't worry about it
eventually someone's going to take
notice and you're going to get a massive
opportunity whether it's within the
company or outside the company power to
overachievers let me go to the next
story can you just point out one thing
about this the the the irony of this
article this is written by Bloomberg
Bloomberg okay Michael Bloomberg the
founder is the definition of an
overachiever he's the top 10 richest
people in the world his net worth is
close to 100 billion dollars I mean the
antithesis of
of what you're basically saying is
Michael Bloomberg but but here's the
thing yeah you're right before even
going go to this article Rob I don't
even know what the author looks like
okay what do you think this person does
for a living okay it makes sense is that
is that her Beth okay let's let's look
her up Beth click on her link and let's
go to her LinkedIn what school you think
she went to maybe Colombia I don't know
what school she went let's let's look up
her profile there she is actually go to
her professor I'm actually curious now
senior columnist uh okay is that her
Cinema Bloomberg okay go go all the way
down to see what school she went to go
all the way down go all the way so she
was at Fortune Magazine before Colombia
boom I guessed there you go and I guess
I didn't even have a clue I guess she
went to Columbia University now of
course they're producing people like
this wow that hate capitalists wow no
wonder is anybody surprised hello folks
the next time your kid says I want to go
to Columbia University this is New Age
journalism this is New Age journalism
not the stuff that we used to get years
ago anyways let me get to the next story
here next story is work from home era
ends for millions of Americans this is
from a real newspaper called Wall Street
Journal a labor department report
released this week shows 72 and a half
percent of business establishments said
their employees telework rarely or not
at all last year compared to 60.1
percent in 2021 the survey showed about
21 million more workers on site
full-time in 2020 to compare with the
prior year several large companies have
said they have their employees to report
in person more often and they said they
began pushing harder to get staff to
work on site more often as recessions
recession fears prompts and increased
emphasis on worker productivity Walt
Disney Company now pushes for four day a
week on site and meta platform inc's uh
Zuck said that in-person time helps
build relationships and get more done
the share of business establishment
hybrid Arrangement where employees split
time between home and workers work site
decrease in all measured Industries in
2022 from 2021 declining 13.4 percent
across the private sector according to
the labor department Tom there is a lot
going on in here and I'm about to go
like to 1.5 mode if that's okay so you
you have all these people that are upset
about work from home well guess what
with the recession coming it's about to
be go back home and you could get laid
off and lose your job here is what's
going on in Tech remember Tech The
Darlings of the liberal side that take
care of other people and make them
special organic pizzas in the Google
cafeteria here we go apple is
threatening to take action and staff who
aren't coming in the office three days a
week and they're going to monitor your
badge to make sure that you do because
they think quote with the recession
coming we need collaboration then Oracle
is forcing some employees to come back
to the office Mark benioff excuse me
excuse me Larry Ellison comes out and
says we've missed the benefit of
in-person collaboration and mentoring
that drives our creativity improves our
decision making it helps us learn from
one another as specially as we come into
a competitive era translation recession
coming let's get in the Huddle and get
[__] done tree number two gone says Mark
benioff has revised the plan to stack
rank the bottom five percent the way GE
used to in the 80s 90s until Jack Welch
retired and he said the annual strategic
plan will include return to office
mandates because we have a vision V2 mom
so V2 mom which stands for Vision Values
methods obstacles and measurements for
the new year and measurements are hard
to take place unless people are here
working together on teams tree number
three then Amazon's HRT sent a memo
rejecting rejected what okay I sound
like chick Hearn here rejected in March
24th just the other day or HRT form
rejected the internal petition by 30
000 amazonians as they prefer to be
called who signed it and said that the
return to office RTO mandate was unfair
to them their comment was we respect the
petition We Appreciate You collaborative
nature in which you brought the issue
forward however the RTO mandate will
that Andy jassy is outlined will stand
we need here it comes again
collaboration and team work I can't
respond to every accommodation request
but this is decision of corporate now
then
guess what you heard in there like seven
times collaboration teamwork
you know recession tough environment let
me tell you you want to complain about
work from home there are Reddit threads
out there right now Pat that are warning
each other hey you know if you have an
opinion but go light on it you don't
want to get targeted if we have to do a
bunch of layoffs and you're on the work
from home and you've been kind of
pushing back too hard against management
be careful so there are voices on the
reddits that are reminding each other
yeah show your opinion but I don't know
if I want my signature on a petition
because if they're looking for layoffs I
don't want to be seen as a troublemaker
whereas corporations it's not about
troublemakers we're about to go into
recession and they're talking about
getting stuff done driving hard and
building stronger businesses during it
and by the way I'm not leaving out Mark
Zuckerberg because you just read in
summary here he says in person time
helps build relationship and get more
done
yeah Adam and I'm sorry I have to cut
you off for everybody who's watching and
me and Adam lately have been really like
into like the planet and Earth all the
trees that you killed can we just take a
moment of just silence for
for all the trees that Tom just killed
for that one bit I appreciate it you're
funny but you know what you know how
sometimes you listen to every single
news station and they use the same line
you know that that one clip that shows
like 75 different anchors all saying the
same thing same thing yeah it's like a
central narrative narrative by the way
you can tell all of these guys also talk
to each other 100 every one of those
guys got on a call and we said let's use
the word collaboration so let's throw a
bunch of warts against the wall which
one do you like the most all those
stories are 72 hours from beginning to
end that everything I pulled it's all
together what do you think are the
chances they had a call together that
they all spoke to each other ten
thousand percent okay I'm with you there
and by the way guess what guess what now
all the people that are saying well you
know if you don't offer a work from home
you know we're just not gonna do this
but but by the way let me tell you a
crazy story I can't tell you Leverage is
over I can't tell you who but you know
who and I'll tell you after the call who
this week two of these big biggest
Bankers in all of America okay very well
known guys we got on a call they're the
best team in that company you know who
they are I call them after six months of
back and forth we're giving them some
money and I said here's some money
I want you to look at them give me some
options investing into things right now
you know what his answer was
he says we'll take the money
and we'll put it in cash and we're not
buying anything right now because we
believe
that SMP is going to go to 35
and there may be a chance that SNP goes
to 32. s p today's around 39.88 around 4
000 okay to go from 30 to like four
thousand to thirty five that's a 15 drop
off okay to go to a 32 that's a 20
something percent drop off exactly 20
drop off to go to 32. so these guys in
all the Big Wall Street guys are all
sitting around saying dinners are
probably a very big you know uh drop off
coming up here soon the next few months
to say they're aligned on the same page
together most of them are it's very rare
you tell a salesperson take some money
go sell me some products make some
commission and for the salesperson to
say what no no how often do you hear a
salesperson saying no to making
commission you rarely hear that okay
this happened to me today's what today's
Tuesday this was on a Friday call that I
had with these guys what do you think of
that approach well first of all I love
that approach you know I love that
approach that's the right approach but
if you do it that way and you know what
I told you I said let me tell you guys
something here I've been around the
block for a long time you treat me right
you'll have me for a lifetime you don't
you don't I said I'm just getting barely
started with making money you know I'm
44 I'm in the money making years we got
20 30 more years of making money there's
going to be more Investments that we're
going to be making together moral the
story is this
more of these guys who are running
companies who laid off 19 000 employees
is it extensions no it's uh I think
Accenture is it Accenture that laid off
19 000 rap yep Accenture to cut the cut
19 000 jobs as it spending slows this is
19. if you can zoom in 19
000 jobs they're laying off right left
and right yesterday Jeff Bezos had a
video Jeff said uh
if you're right now sitting around
seeing what's going on the marketplace
everybody is bracing for recession to
come and it's coming Jeff is talking
about he says the advice I would give to
the average person is if you got some
money take some money off to take some
chips off the table if you got some
savings don't make any crazy decisions
right now that's what Jeff is talking
about because we don't know how bad it's
going to be the direction we're going on
unemployment we're going to experience
all of this stuff that's coming here
right and all of those guys are now
going to say well if you don't let me
work from home four days a week I will
not work for you because I got four
other options you know what you should
say now I totally understand sweetheart
go somewhere else
because this isn't a place for you
that's what all of those guys are saying
together and they're very aligned that
Leverage is over you're you are so right
and it's not leveraged on that abuse is
over yes yeah the companies felt abused
the employee thought they had leverage
and but it turns out to be fake leverage
and by the way this is censure this is
not Amazon saying we're laying off what
was it I think Amazon was like 19 000
plus nine and they came back and it was
like 27 000 overall this is censure this
is not warehouse workers that's freaking
Accenture these are Highly Educated
white collar workers and finance
accounting and professional Consulting
yeah 9 000 more in addition to eighteen
thousand yeah so so uh and Central is
like I'll see your eighteen thousand and
raise you a thousand by the way we
talked about this I want to say you can
tell me to date on this we talked about
this at the peak of covet
where it was we talked about how if you
can go get a raise go get it go dude do
you remember that conversation and I
said don't do it I said I'm telling you
don't do it it's gonna backfire no go do
it all those years of Social Capital you
had with a company when you left you
lost it all of that loyalty the
relationships all of that you lost it
it's gone right you don't have that
anymore the people that didn't do that
they deserve to be recognized those who
did do that they're paying a price today
I believe we were well they're
mercenaries right what does the
mercenary do could have been invoke
you're right I think it was a bulk of
thing yeah what does a mercenary do a
mercenary shows up for the temporary war
and then goes off somewhere else
they're paid soldiers so if people
wanted to be mercenaries working for
Amazon and then Amazon now lays them off
because they're like these folks here
are dedicated and working man what goes
around comes around you know as they say
fafo you know so oh
and guess what people are finding right
now level 10 of that experience so let's
go rob can you pull up the article on
what happened with Nashville and go
through the story if I want to read it
so okay so a tragic event that just took
place at this point everybody knows
about this six killed in Nashville
shooting uh victims identified three of
them were nine-year-olds the names are
given on this article we don't need to
go through the names two of them were
teachers one of them was a substitute
teacher 61 years old the other one was a
custodian and the other one was 60 years
old the head of the Covenant School was
killed by this girl that is a
transgender identifies as a transgender
I'll read this to you a uh uh shortly
after 10 a.m okay three adults the
shooter 28 years old Audrey Hale who
once attended this school was killed
after being confronted by officers below
is what we know about this development
shortly after 10 a.m on Monday shooter
opened fire at Covenant School a private
Christian School attached to a church
enrolling roughly 200 students from a
pre-k through sixth grade with 30
faculty members of Metropolitan
Nashville Police Department said the
shooter who was armed with an AR style
rifle and an AR style pistol and a
shotgun and how can she carry enter the
school through a locked side entrance
after shooting the door down
the Asylum should Rob if you can find a
video because there's a video of her
walking in go to Twitter type it and
you'll find this Twitter's easiest way
to find it the Silent Shot at the
victims in a lobby of the building she
targeted random students in the school
whoever she came in uh contact with she
fired rounds uh the M mnpd Chief John
Drake the first call for the shooting
came at 1013 police officers quickly
responded and shooter fired at officer
through the window on the second floor
police entered the building confronting
the Killer and shoot on the second floor
that the attack lasted 14 minutes
according to the police early Monday
afternoon spokesperson of Vanderbilt
University Vanderbilt Medical Center
confirmed that three children were taken
to the hospital gunshots has uh they've
died from gunshot wounds let me see the
picture with the father and the daughter
it's just it's heart this is tough man
to see what's going on here uh uh it's
it's it's tragic yeah right there look
at look at her going through this is
this is her
um how much email it was a female that
now identified it's a man yeah but let
me explain something when the corner
shows up when the show listen the corner
shows up and they do the autopsy it's a
female so let's just let's just put that
to bed but you were just about to say
well you were saying you said the moment
this happened yesterday you were driving
past schools and what did you see right
now driving past right off the rip Pat
um I drove by two schools on the way to
my house there's already cop cars
sitting and I'm pretty sure everybody in
America is seeing this right now there's
cop cars without the sirens on just like
that cop right there with their lights
on as a deterrent okay and there's two
two points I want to hit back uh Christy
prades who writes for valuetainment some
she wrote an article called it's not a
gun problem it's a mental health problem
when she talks about how at what point
because let's be honest okay there's
you're not going to take away guns from
Americans because the moment you do a
gun grab the majority of the people like
me Pat like you that own legal guns
you're gonna take all our guns away and
then you think all the gangsters from
all the Chicago they're gonna go okay
you know what the government asks for
our guns let's give it back but she made
a good point I was talking to my boy
Mike when we came in here path when are
we gonna address the opioid crisis the
drugs the suicide rates going up she did
it she did a good part in this which it
was according
the list goes on and on the lack of
faith about Christianity and no is a
Christian school and I think she went he
she whatever she she went she went to
that school uh Christy wrote this
according to gun violence archives there
has been a 130 U.S mass shootings in the
first quarter of 2023 89 of them have
been school shootings the full number of
shootings in 2022 counted 647. when are
we going to take a little step back
because you know automatically the
government's going to say up everybody
guns give me your guns give me your guns
it was actually quite embarrassing
yesterday Joe Biden spoke and the
shooting already happened you know what
he came downstairs and said in the white
house
because it's a little bit uncomfortable
uncomfortable should I should I preface
it pat yeah he comes downstairs Pat and
he's joking about good I get it guys
he's he's he has dementia he's out there
he starts talking about ice cream and
how he loves ice cream and how they have
ice cream upstairs and then he sees four
kids and he's like look at how beautiful
these kids are make them stand up it's
like what
you have to be this is right after the
shooting yeah he goes I'll go back here
my name is Joe Biden my name is Joe
Biden
I'm Dr Joe Biden's husband six people
just died she's not a doctor's ice cream
chocolate chip
I came down because you heard there was
chocolate chip ice cream look at this
I'm Ridiculous by the way I have a whole
refrigerator to pull upstairs yeah yeah
and then what about the one and then and
then he spots four kids in the back and
he's like look who's beautiful kids are
those if any was this for him to talk
about the shooting
he's supposed to be talking about the
shooting because I mean it happened
regardless of what he he addresses it
later on Pat but let me explain
something to you how the tone death of
of this moment yeah he's lost it but
there's people that are dead like the
first thing you should be talking about
is that not joking around okay so right
by the way check this out no just pause
it whether he's going to talk about it
or not look at the time at the top yeah
it's live it's 2 43
eastern time this was at 10 A.M eastern
time it's been four four hours and 43
minutes since the incident and you're
joking he's he's having a good time but
my parents lost a nine-year-old child
okay a 261 year old teacher and a
custodian and a 60 year old dean of the
school head of the school and you're
joking about this he's happy about but
not happy about it I'm just saying I'm
not saying she's happy no I'm saying I'm
saying he's he's told her I'm going to
say two things Pat and here's what is
besides the mental health that Christy
was talking about when are we gonna okay
can we at least try something different
I know when you have this conversation
of more guns if you see a cop Pat if you
see a cop car somewhere and you know
what the the Target by where I live
there's a cop car Pat just chilling
sitting there no cop is there you know
what that does that makes somebody
that's thinking about doing some
squirrely [__] out of their shooting or
stealing I'm not gonna go there why
don't we try for the sake of these kids
and God rest all the souls of all the
people that passed away put some armed
professional people just in the schools
there we talked about this we talked
about levik we talk about this on a
couple different podcasts 99 000 public
schools in the U.S 60 000 a year hired
retired military police officers that
six billion dollar per year we give
Ukraine 140 billion dollars but Kitty
kept the kids for safe for another 14
years by the way I don't know the exact
numbers but that sounds about right and
we talked about why not make the
investment to do that 14 minutes is how
long this person was in there before 13
minutes you know what's 14 minutes you
know what's 14 minutes so how in 40
minutes how many places can you walk in
this building in a park you can walk up
and down this thing 10 times in 14
minutes so by the way the fact that and
I know this is going to sound strange it
could have been way more than six in 14
minutes right okay it could have been
way more than six and fourteen minutes
question was asked of one of the uh
heads in charge saying hey what could
you have done you know the door was
locked are you guys going to do anything
different to put a cop in front of all
the doors you can't put a cop in front
of all the doors so you know the risk is
going to be there but for for for for
you to I mean you know how
certain security you have in place to
protect certain buildings that you walk
in and it triggers something there's got
to be a better technology like by the
way this is a great opportunity for an
innovator and an entrepreneur to be
looking at the same there's a major need
for this parents would support it if the
this whatever technology you come up
with it costs XYZ amount of money that
school can go to the parents and say hey
for this much money we can offer this
kind of protection for the schools are
you guys up for it private Enterprise
can do it this is a private school
public needs to go figure out a way to
address this uh but if it keeps
happening over and over again there's
got to be a way to address this issue
and why won't they impact if it keeps
happening and you're not giving us any
other can we at least try something can
we put armed professional not PTSD
veterans because like Pat me I was a cop
in the military you know I'm really good
at shooting put somebody like me in
there because think about it pat let's
just say for for doubles that you're
you're the shooter Adam and you're
thinking about going to this school if
you know somebody like me is in there
you might pick a different School am I
right what's this rap so this is a
bulletproof safe room that they've
installed inside of a school in the
United States to help students and
teachers uh in case so 22 million views
press play
foreign
oh wow oh that's sick
oh wow and then you just go in there in
the corner and then that's it oh wow
that's that's actually pretty good um my
point of view whenever I first
came in here and I saw this I was like
oh my goodness see I love that yeah
that's amazing then now it comes down to
cost it comes down to a bunch of
different things but I love that yeah I
love it for some like that to be in
place go ahead Tom
you know when you defund the police this
is what you get I mean we're going to
talk a little bit later about Portland
and what's happening to the economy up
there but there are private schools that
are already doing things right now and
unfortunately
um
you know this one got through but uh
there were two things here
the number of victims or could have been
was much higher and I think these police
also learned
um from Texas and what happened at
Uvalde remember the police waited
outside and they were strategizing an
hour and 14 minutes correct an hour and
four we've been in here for less than an
hour I saw yesterday said these police
were armoring up running from the patrol
cars you know what I'm saying the
secondary armor Pat you know and the
helmet and everything and they were
going in and they were getting live
briefing they figured out where they
were and they didn't
take any moments they were like okay
second floor up here in and up so they
didn't wait the the police here Pat
didn't wait it was 14 minutes which is
14 minutes too long but they learned a
lot from Vivaldi about the local law
enforcement saying hey you know what I I
have to arm her up and I gotta get in
and I got to be be up and I think
schools need to understand it would not
take you know tremendous investment
there are schools already that I visit
you go through the front doors which is
like a weather door it's kind of like in
the Northeast where you have the weather
door at a restaurant and then you walk
in there's a second door you know that
little square area well the it is so
easy to make those bulletproof and
basically you know crash proof and then
you have the little camera there anybody
been to a school where you have that
situation walk through the first thing
it's it it
and one security guard a roaming
security guard and the 14 minutes is
going to come down to four minutes it's
just the willingness to do it it's there
the cost is not huge and this so the
willingness to do it one side will say
take away all the guns this will solve
the issue okay and then a mentally ill
person is going to put okay let's thank
you Pat I'm going to interrupt you on
that Timothy McVeigh went to a freaking
Home Depot and loaded up a truck with
fertilizer if you are Oklahoma City yeah
if you are mentally deranged you can
find low-tech common things to carry it
out your car you can just drive through
a group of on a playground that's that
correct you can drive through oh this
has never happened driving the SUV
through people celebrating a sports
Victory never heard of you know while
yelling out the window never happens
yeah the mental the the people that are
mentally challenged we need to raise the
American consciousness of it's not just
about when George Bush said if you see
something say something you know about
people you know certain people walking
around and looking suspicious this is we
have mentally Disturbed people in this
country that need help and we need to
harden the schools and also we need to
proactively be looking at it and what
you're talking about about fentanyl it's
the the list it's a multi-point yeah
it's a multi-point issue that that
people on the left just want to say it's
all about the guns no it's not
I feel like like this country used to be
all about the children love and protect
the children kids kids yo they don't got
a freaking chance they're getting
sexualized left and right you know what
I mean they don't give a damn about them
in school like bro they're in school you
have to protect these innocent people
and I'm sorry and I I know it people
from the left are like what morgue fired
a step of fire no you have to stop the
bad guys and sometimes you gotta arm the
good guys to fight the bad guys and I'm
sorry that's what it is bro put me in
that school I guarantee you that person
wouldn't have had 14 minutes to do [__]
by the way you know you know what's the
one state that has
the lowest crime in all of America that
a lot of people are moving to right now
and no one's talking about it you know
what state it is I'll guess Idaho okay
do you know Idaho is one of the states
at the top
with the most people who have a license
to carry it's eight percent okay
licensed to carry you go to a restaurant
there's 10 people there one of them is
caring yeah okay so guess what happens
you want to go rob a place go rob a
place so now to the people that are
saying if we bang guns that's the
solution no problem there's something
called Data Chicago leads the way okay
Baltimore leads the way you can go to a
lot of these states and cities with
strong gun laws and see how it's working
out it's called case study if you go to
a business school to get an MBA an
average MBA grad is going to go through
hundreds of case studies that they look
at here's Amazon case study here's
Lululemon case study here's Apple case
study and you'll see what's working and
what's not working there's plenty of
case studies for that and people are
going to lose their minds when they talk
about this here's the other part
pull up the Tweet between the exchange
between JD Vance and Keith Olbermann so
watch this JD Vance uh uh Senator out of
Ohio yeah so we're still learning about
the horrific shooting in Nashville but
if early reports are accurate that's a
trans shooter targeted a Christian
School there needs to be a lot of soul
searching on the extreme left giving in
to these ideas isn't compassion it's
dangerous look what Keith Oberman says
number one you're remarkably stupid and
a hateful creature or B why don't you
use that little brain power you have to
explain the irrelevant reality here this
is an alumni of a Christian School who
targeted it right so so so the back and
forth of you know a commentary with
these guys first they don't want to
identify this is a trans 100 individual
okay and and to go through that and try
to normalize it is potentially causing
some of this I think the the time when
you when you see someone like this
exchange with
our buddy and that article I sent you
with the Tennessee uh what was the
newspaper The Tennessean where it says
in there if you read the article it says
the suspect Who police have identified
as a 28 year old transgender man
entered a school through a side entrance
and began shooting
identified if you can just control F
Ctrl F put transgender you'll find that
sentence there it is put control F
identified as a
uh identified as a 20 year old
transgender man
so here's here's what becomes when
they're trying to play these types of
games yeah I'm so confused there's a big
difference between ideological beliefs
and demands
don't make me sit there and say no you
have to be more compassionate no no no
no you believe that more power to you
this has happened and we have to give
Credence to that as well that maybe
there's some issues going on here with
individuals like this that are coming in
wanting to do something the first thing
you want to talk about is what the first
tweet Biden has right after this event
guess what it was talking about take on
laws yeah take away your guns everybody
was talking about thinking away guns not
necessarily taking away guns yeah it
starts off with over regulating with
guns is uh what the what the
conversation starts with Chrissy sent me
the a clip of Benny Johnson who Elon
Musk liked the cop this shooter was
trans the Colorado Springs shooter
identified as non-binary the Denver
shooter identified as trans the Aberdeen
shooter identified as trans the natural
shooter identifies as trans there's
something going on like we said mental
where you have to check that's number
one everybody's always going to go for
the guns what the hell is going on with
people the younger suicide rate is at an
all-time high mental disorders all these
problems we have to go back to the
person that's behind the trigger not the
gun itself and until we do that Pat
you're gonna keep seeing this they're
going to keep killing innocent people
until that changes but they do you think
they give a damn his job their goal the
government is to disarm us the Second
Amendment is for what to stop from
tyranny from your government so when the
government is telling me give me your
gun I don't believe you think that's
gonna happen in our lifetime taking away
our God no I I don't think so Pat but
and and this was the thing people always
like well they got lasers and they could
kill you if they want to okay could do
all the laser stuff but at least when
you guys come to get me I'm taking one
of one of them out that's it I want to
have my gun do you think they're going
to take guns away from us in our
lifetime no I think it's going to be
progressively regulated and I think at
some point in time you're gonna have the
right mix in Washington and they're
going to declare X number of weapons to
be assault weapons and you'll notice
also in this article did you catch the
little AR style pistol I don't know what
an AR style pistol is and what they're
attempting to do is to create use AR
almost as profanity or danger and apply
you see what I mean yeah assault rifle
yeah and and which doesn't stand for
assault rifles but um as you know yeah
of course but um they don't and I I
think In Our Lifetime we're gonna see
we're gonna see that start you don't
need a machine gun to kill Bambi and
other things like that is what you're
going to hear it but I think we'll see
that in our lifetime but I don't think
we're gonna see a ban in our lifetime
I'll just say one thing I I don't think
that we're going to see um guns being
taken away but my biggest fear is that
as As Americans we're becoming
desensitized to these types of tragedies
okay because this is in the news cycle
right now
um by tomorrow it'll be gone and that's
the reality of it whether it was
Columbine whether it's Sandy Hook
whether it's Uvalde whether it's
Parkland that was just 10 minutes up the
street from here uh whether it's here in
Nashville it's like this is becoming
part of Americana and that is [__]
disgusting to me and what's the
definition of crazy doing the same thing
over and over and over again and
expecting different results so we need
to figure out what Solutions can be
implemented aside from taking away guns
because I don't think that's a solution
I think that's a great idea of putting
cops and security guards and ex-military
in front of every single school in
America why is that not already done
already and this is going to be a little
contrarian View and this is sort of the
antithesis of what our judicial system
is I think that if you commit a mass
murder tragedy your family should have
to pay some repercussions with what you
do I agree 100
how the legal system works but at what
point are we just going to say oh this
psychopath came into school we killed
him he killed six kids ten kids 20 kids
kids up justice served yeah what's gonna
happen to this person's parents I agree
how did he get the guns who put him in
the house 100 who's taking care of this
person I know there's gonna be people
out there saying no that's not how the
judicial system works well whatever's
working right now ain't [__] working
something's got to change well you're
right and by the way you can tell those
people it is how the judicial system
works find out what happens if you have
a kid under 18 years old that goes in
and breaks a window at a neighbor's
house or or has a car crash in a
neighbor's craft find out who has to pay
for that it's the parents the parents of
that of that under 18 year old and So
you you're exactly right and I think
people need to understand this is how
the justice system works and there are
parents that are getting sued for the
acts of their children including
assaults under the age of 18. and this
person was 28 so who do you punish
that person probably has a cat or
multiple cats you work taking all your
cats I don't care if it's their best
friend I don't care if it's their aunt
their Uncle their Grandma their dad
whoever the closest person is your logic
behind that though like I think because
if you want to kill the if you kill this
person tell me okay yeah who's paying
the price
I'm asking you who's paying the price
okay the families will be grieving no
the children are dead totally get it at
what point at what point are decisions
you make your decisions not those who
raised your raised you decisions at what
point obviously you have to take
ownership of the decisions you make but
we're talking about vengeance here and
consequences
you know but that shooter doesn't care
about consequences that's why they're
going into a shop
I'm assuming that every person that does
this has someone close to them yeah that
they care about yep okay and just follow
the math who do they live with who takes
care of that that's a different story so
let me show you a text exchange she had
that day I don't know if you guys have
seen the text or not let me send it to
you uh Rob did I send it to you or no
okay let me send this text to you and
show this because this this is
disturbing so somebody knew this was
about to happen and this is the part
where Adam's argument gets some Credence
this person needs to be held accountable
if you can show I send it to your
computer and I send it to your uh to
your phone this is the text exchange
zoom in
so basically that post I made on here
about you that was basically a suicide
note I'm planning to die today this is
not a joke you'll probably hear about me
on the news after I die this is my last
goodbye I love you see you again in
another life Audrey you have so much
more life to live I pray God keeps and
covers and cover you cover you and then
boom and no no like you have to be on
the phone calling and then maybe 911 FBI
because this person go to whoever Aiden
is okay Step Up needs to pay a price
I agree okay because you call the cops
because if there is an understanding
from Audrey that oh if I do this Aiden
who I love will spend
their life in jail have ramifications
all you need to do is think twice like
something needs to happen here let me
but but
based on the law right now
Aiden is not responsible for anything
but we knew that this was going to
happen I think this this text from Aiden
like even if listen she he whatever I'm
not going to get into this game uh
basically I don't know if this person
this is a suicide note if even if you
love this person you gotta go try to
find out help them call the cops because
this is like a cry for help like I'm
gonna kill myself there was no mention
about killing or or shooting the kids
but like I think Aiden needs to be on
the ball you ever had you ever had
people in your life close to you that
said they're gonna kill themselves I had
one person once they like they were
really really close Pat I not only
called the the parent I called 9-1-1 and
I was speeding to their house to make
sure that they're okay they didn't do it
and they're doing great Cops show up
cops did show up the bomb showed up she
was hitting the person real attempt was
she it was he he wanted to end it he was
on his like he was sad
I've never had someone say that I've
been around depressed people that said
I've contemplated it but it was usually
a very rational conversation where they
were saying they contemplated but no one
called me at that moment and said hey
I'm out of here how about you Adam
um indirectly yeah like so so
sometimes if you have somebody like this
in your life
this is their way of getting attention
and you don't know which one's going to
be real and which one's not yeah so one
time somebody did this to me one too
many times and it would ruin my day fear
concern I had to go disruption at the
highest level
so a regular day they say this and you
have to go to check what's going on
what's going on finally I'm like this
last time middle day I'm in a business
appointment meeting this person calls
and says I just took this many pills I'm
taking my own life
and I said no problem
I'm calling the cops they're on their
way no no don't call the cops no I'm
calling the cops cops showed up good and
cops went there took this person to the
hospital took him to the mental hospital
got everything checked out and uh they
said you want to take your life no no I
don't want to take my life so why are
you telling
this person you want to take your life
long story short that behavior stop when
you have people like this in your life
they're oh man it's it's not it's easy
to make the claims that you make right
like you know you talk about your father
openly
Nobody Knows the life you lived with him
right nobody knows it you can tell the
stories but we're going to be like come
on Adam you know we're like no I'm
telling you this is what happened to me
so who can take that away from you
nobody can take that away from you you
you probably no matter how many hours
you took to try to explain to us what
it's like we're only gonna know less
than five percent of it is that a fair
assessment to say we're going to less
than five percent of it to have people
like this in you I feel to me I feel
sorry
for having people like this in your life
so how what leads to people being like
this okay let's go through a couple
things I'm spitballing I don't know just
I'm just openly talking so what gets
somebody to get to a place like this one
is upbringing yeah 100 credibility
the credit there goes to parents good or
bad yeah uh okay schooling where you
grew up the school you go to uh teachers
Society drug tears drugs teach uh
doctors I had a dentist that was selling
Vicodin to my friend my best friend he
was selling Vicodin to I went and found
the dentist I went and found the dealer
and I had a very interesting
conversation with them but I lost my
friend by then he committed suicide he
died it was too late so you know who do
you give credit to who gets
responsibility for this parents you know
some parents raise their kids well and
they go to a school and somebody gets a
hold of them and you lost them I had a
good friend of mine at the house the the
individual I spoke to about are you know
before I started Insurance Company this
the guy I spoke to Bill and Beth his
wife they were over attacks we're having
a conversation together and he was
saying as a parent whatever you do
between 0 and 12 that's it that stays
from the day the kid is born till 12
that's your shot at giving this kid a
chance at life like to make the right
choices the values the principles so
does a bit of the credit goes to how
this person was raised zero to twelve
almost everybody I meet that is
willing to have a conversation about
this I always go to tell me your father
your relationship with your dad I hate
him
really what happened he was never there
okay I mean that's natural rage you're
going to have I can't tell you how often
when I'm talking to someone trans get
whatever it may be yeah my father's an
[__] my father's a diss sometimes
it's I have a good relation my mom and
my dad okay cool but sometimes it's not
um you know the the this you have to
look at what caused this and see if any
of it we can control and then no matter
how much of it we can't control some of
it we just can't control I agree if if
if if God gave us the free will to make
the choices that we make that means some
of the choices we make
are going to be horrible choices this
person made a horrible choice you ruined
six people's lives how long is it going
to take for those people to stop
mourning and recovering especially the
nine-year-olds are you kidding me oh
that scar is permanent oh permanent that
that takes place that's not an Impulse
it was a plan yeah and and Pat I respect
again I know people are going to be like
oh we quit listen at least the guy is
giving us give me an option give me
other things because we talked about
Adam back in the day bro when it was
like these terrorists that are doing
stuff guess what you do this just giving
you a heads up your wife that you love
and you're I'm sorry when it comes I
mean that we would we went extreme but
um Adam when you were talking about
putting the the you know veterans or the
ex-cops and and schools and you know
what argument you're gonna get do you
know how expensive that's gonna be okay
then guess what let's do a Haul on the
what 300 million dollars we're sending
to [__] Ukraine and put it into
protecting our people our kids and our
schools let's stop giving other people
money and protect this war that's going
on I can't put a price on saving our
kids that's what I'm saying
gets no more money to to anybody until
we figure out that solution so don't
give me the we don't got money to
protect the kids [__] argument I
hate that when I hear that it drives me
bananas okay there's money you just
don't want to do it because their goal
is to take away our guns anyways you
know every every American can engage on
the uh Mental Health crisis and I'll
tell you how I I was listening to
something it was a quick summary I
understand psychologists and psych uh
psychiatrists may be listening will will
say it's over simplification I'm not the
expert I'm repeating what I heard they
said look there's there's two major
sides here one side is true deep mental
illness uh delusional episode
schizophrenia uh drug addictions that
bring across things and and you're on
one side of the fence where it's real
you know mental illness and a huge
Challenge on the other side of the fence
you have
um sisw self-image self-worth and that
bring depression and you have a lot of
that right now that's showing in the
studies on social media about girls with
this social media being an endless
comparison playing field and oh I didn't
get as many likes I guess I'm not as
pretty my um the little uh video I made
wasn't as good you know I'm not as crazy
I'm not as cute and so you have
self-image self-worth and depression
that is the side that all Americans can
work on and it's called put the phone
down and have conversations with kids
um I really admire Adam when he talks
about his nephew and the things he does
with his nephew because that is an
example whenever I'm around my friend's
kids I always do the silly little thing
with handshakes because it puts value on
a person and it puts recognition and
you're looking into their eyes but
there's things all of us can do as
Americans and it starts with putting the
phone down and having face-to-face
conversations with people because the
mental health side of things you know
you may be helping somebody on the
self-image self-worth side and these
things would go to depression if you go
to the movies recently uh how many of us
have seen it anybody seen the Dove
commercial aimed at girls and social
media self-worth that that they show
before the movies no and they talk about
hey put the phone down you look good she
said maybe I'll do this maybe I'll do
that and they're like put the phone down
you're beautiful yeah right and so you
have Dove out there if they're trying to
sell soap and they're trying to do it to
be politically active and be on the
right side of an argument but there's a
deep truth that goes in there
um and I think all of us can reach out
from these digital relationships and and
be intentional about personal
relationships it's amazing that you say
that Tom because you just went full
circle to when we started about uh
social media apps like Tick Tock and
everything and all that it's a war for
the Youth and driving like those type of
people are losing their minds because
they have no identity they don't know
it's all a battle of who like me my
video this this and that and it comes
full circle to where we're at a war and
it's a it's like I said it's not a
ground war where they're shooting guns
and everything that's the word that
they're doing okay I heard it described
as the endless comparison playing field
and the kids are trapped on it how many
likes should I get is my video as funny
as theirs all the things that go then
this endless comparison playing field
and nobody's there's always going to be
somebody more something better or
something there and then you're gonna
feel
bad you feel well I'm just not there uh
and feel less about it and it's it's all
happening in the digital realm not face
to face
what page is that go ahead finish this
no I'm just going to finish this thought
uh my my biggest fear against is is just
what's next do you recall when the
Uvalde shooting was in San Antonio area
what do you think that was a year
it was May 24th 2022. so less than a
year ago okay so here's just some stats
for you there's been 13 school shootings
this year that resulted in injuries or
death we're only three months into the
Year guys there have been 157 shootings
since 2018. 51 school shootings with
injuries and death last year 2022 the
most in a single year since education
week began tracking such incidents of
2018. there were 35 incidents in 2021 10
in 2020 and 24 each in 2019 and 2018. so
they're going up
um
it's it's just so sad and it's so tragic
and there's no price that you can put on
protecting children's lives when they're
in school
and Congress and and senators and
representatives and the president
figure this [__] out I know it's not
that hard but we you know I mean if we
could put [__] on Mars in all these
places you can't figure out here's the
thing here's the thing if if they can
unite on Tick-Tock they can unite on
this so why don't you unite on this and
see what you can do you know the left is
going to say can we
uh do background checks can we do
training can we do this and the right's
gonna say can we instead of sending
money to here put some money into this
but they're going to have to go back and
forth to figure this thing out the
question about what they eventually take
the guns away in our lifetime the answer
is most likely no
but will some states yes and what's
going to happen to those States they're
going to lose people who feel more
protected having guns and they're going
to go to states that allow you to have
guns and they're gonna defend the Second
Amendment and the same way where people
left LA California they left New York
they left Illinois to come to States
like
Florida Texas and some other states is
the same way you're going to see people
leaving and a quiet State like Idaho is
gradually going to grow and attract
certain markets there's going to be
States like that that are
have a higher freedom score higher
values and principal score which we'll
get into here in a minute of all through
Journal article they're going to attract
those people so I do think some states
are going to go away why is there no
committee on this I'm I don't know if
there is I'm asking why is there no
committee on this there probably is I
would I I would say there probably is
and if there isn't they well that's not
president Adam that's not it's Ukraine
is a situation and the Committees
there's bipartisan groups that come
together I mean there's a January 6th
committee okay how is there not a school
shooting committee save the kids with
five Democrats five Republicans figure
this out let's get to the next story
here again our condolences goes out to
those six families who had this event
happened to them yesterday no matter how
much we talk about it those guys are the
ones that are having the biggest pain
right now having to explain this to your
siblings of the nine-year-old of what
just happened this is not an easy
situation for them uh our uh condolences
goes out to those families so next story
Cracker Barrel becomes latest company to
flee Portland amid Rising crime retail
theft
it is closing its final eateries in the
Portland metro area citing the impact of
kova 19 pandemic on its business the
closure are in Beaverton Tualatin and
bend our effective March 20th a
spokesperson for Cracker Barrel said the
pandemic had many had made it difficult
to staff and profitably run the stores
Walmart announced it was closing all of
its Portland stores in February citing
financial reasons the seal Walmart had
previously warned that stores would
close if retail crime didn't subside
crime and homelessness have been growing
issues in Portland over the past couple
of years
would over 2 600 downtown businesses
failing filling a change of address with
the U.S Postal Service a Nike store in
northeast Portland abruptly closed in
November 2022 just a couple months ago
after string of brazen shoplifting
incidents a real estate developer and
lifelong Portland native Dustin Michael
Miller said the city was out of control
and unrecognizable Tom what do you have
to say about the story you wanted to
defend the police
you wanted to say that people are just
acting out because of Decades of um you
know discrimination
you got it and this is the unintended
consequences and so why don't we just
substitute retail theft for excessive
gun control and that is exactly what is
happening in Oregon people are leaving
and now the law-abiding citizens and the
people that love Oregon like this guy
here says it's out of control and
unrecognizable unrecognizable means he
recognizes a time when it was different
when it was a time for his family and
what he was doing but this is not going
to stop defund the police this is the
polluted pond at the end so now what do
you do with the polluted Pond you go
Upstream you see what polluted it and
the Upstream problem was you allowed
what was the name of that little they
gave a name to the uh Rob the downtown
area they called it the something the
chat the chasing yeah where some people
took over the the downtown Portland
I think it's called yeah they called it
something
no cops will be allowed here and this is
what's going on here and occupy Portland
yeah it's and so you got it you got what
you asked for you know and it's terrible
and look what's happened to the
citizenry that was not behind that you
know 100 of the people in Portland
voters were not in favor of defund the
police they were not in favor of you
know oh just let the looters go it's you
know just sort of economic
redistribution really you here's the
outcome everything's closing you you
have an uninhabitable City now what
exactly the fact that they were blaming
Clover it's like no just just be honest
and say listen we messed up we supported
the wrong policies but you know what I
love about this what here's what I love
about this you know
18 years ago I'm 25 years old we're
sitting in a room
with a bunch of other guys who are
around the same age and we started at
the same time with this insurance
company and everybody is bragging about
the fact that one thing's bigger than
the other they're harder working they're
better leaders they're better Builders
of leaders all this other stuff right
you know how the meeting ended I said
we'll know in about 10 or 20 years oh
wow and and that's how this thing works
you realize one guy slowed down at a
certain number one guy the attention got
to his head one guy was all about the
girls he was always distracted by the
girls the other guy was arrogance the
other guy was ethics the other guy was a
Christian guy who was very happy he
reached a number and he was cool with it
he didn't want to keep continuing going
he was doing good for himself no problem
but eventually you learned who the real
big thinker was time
reveals a lot of things time reveals a
good friendship time reveals a good
relationship time reveals a good economy
time reveals a bad policy time reveals a
good politician time reveals a good
Administration Time Will Reveal
everything it's either your best friend
or your worst enemy nobody beats time
nobody time is going to get you if you
do right eventually the Market's going
to say listen man whether you like this
guy or not we got to give him credit
when you were screaming off the top of
your lungs how amazing your policies
were about defunding to police like Tom
said guess what it's show now
ah not a good idea not a good idea we're
leaving you when you were screaming
about the fact that hey let's put double
mask and all this stuff in the state of
California and do you remember when it
was text people who are not wearing a
mask or they're out there not respecting
the uh what is it the uh non-essential
text and we'll give you 200 if you can
tell people who are out there snitching
on them that's mayor Garcetti when they
had the texting concept guess what yeah
people don't want that they left yeah
bad policies eventually get exposed you
cannot fake bad policies it's happened
in San Francisco Listen to this story
with San Francisco tell me this makes
any sense so how many guys would like it
if somebody in your community put up a
free library for kids who can't afford
to read books to go read books a lot and
it's free at their own cost at their own
cost they're not even asking you to pay
for anything with this right so this
family
in San Francisco couple decides to do
this and watch what happens it's page 15
store if you want to go to it so San
Francisco is forcing couple to remove
sidewalk obstruction or pay 1400 fine
it's a little Free Library okay and by
the way this story is by Insider it's
not even a story by Fox or anybody else
it's an Insider story on the left the
city of San Francisco has been cracking
down on unpermitted projects that
interfere with public ways including a
little Free Library owned by Susan and
Joe Myers who were threatened with a
1402 fine if they did not remove it from
the sidewalk in front of their house the
Crackdown is part of the effort to
remove decade-old awnings on businesses
in Chinatown benches constructed by
residents and other unpermitted objects
the library is popular in the Myers
neighborhood and many residents staged a
campaign to save it resulting in the
letters to the city from locals
including a young girl who begged please
do not destroy Joe and Susan's Library
City officials have responded by saying
they will do everything they can to make
sure it stays in place the Myers could
have obtained a permit for 1402 to keep
their library but they decided instead
to work to change the system as a result
City officials are considering cheaper
permits around five dollars for
similarly free libraries and benches and
this is in a city San Francisco which if
you've been in San Francisco 20 years
ago incredible City yeah if you've been
to San Francisco recently it ain't the
same San Francisco and that's their
flight I'm sorry and so bad thing about
the city is is gone to [__] part of my
French and this is what you're worried
about this is what's pissing the people
1400 bucks
how small that thing is it's small it's
a little baby a little baby angel it's
not in the way of people walking that's
right next to
but that's the fight pat pat not the
homeless guy doing crack and shooting up
[__] and they're giving them drugs on
the right that is pissing people off
well now we know the uh now we know how
the math Works in San Francisco you want
to put a free library up to actually
help people in your neighborhood
fourteen hundred and two dollars taking
a dump on their front lawn is free right
so that's so let's go back and take a
look at this is an example you know of
you know a of a liberal City Hall that's
just lost its freaking mind and it it is
indefensible even the residents of San
Francisco have to look up and say wait
wait what I still have needles on the
streets and you're still giving out
bleach kits and uh clean needles and
you're giving these out because oh we
don't want the addicts to get HIV well
no problem that way he won't have HIV
when he has a fentanyl overdose on
Tuesday great and you have all this
stuff going on homelessness is a problem
and not just the homelessness but the
theft that goes with the homelessness
and the disease and what's happening and
the filth that's there that goes with
the homelessness okay so you're not
doing anything about that and by the way
to keep the police department from being
overwhelmed you know petty theft at like
500 is uh non-punishable they don't even
give you a jaywalking ticket nothing and
I think they raised it to a thousand
somebody's I've done the chat and called
me out if that's not right but I think
they raised that so they did that so
that they wouldn't be overwhelmed so
that basically what it tells thieves you
know coach bagged three thousand dollars
in a Louis Vuitton bag two thousand
dollars don't take that laptop 9.99
perfect you know make sure that whatever
you take is under the threshold so that
you know you're not going to be
prosecuted so the liberal City Hall does
this and then suffers the embarrassment
and this is embarrassment from both
sides of the aisle on a nationwide basis
that something good that somebody
actually tried to do in the shadow of a
city doing nothing gets penalized no
good deed goes unpunished in San
Francisco yeah I'll just say this this
is where I went I just I wanted to see
what the most liberal cities are and
what the most conservative cities are
and it's not even close like how much
bigger the liberal cities are versus the
most conservative cities and and
I just think it's one of those things
where the bigger your city gets the more
people you have the more population and
the diverse opinions and the diversity
of racial Equity inclusion all that kind
of stuff like that the more nonsensical
uh things tend to get because you're
dealing with so many people and so many
differences of opinions and then you're
trying to regulate and over regulate and
the nonsense and then you'd enter the
you know like Tom's talking about uh
defund the police and BLM and you're
dealing with so much stuff so here's a
list of the top 10 most liberal cities
uh San Francisco number one by far too
D.C Seattle Oakland Boston Minneapolis
Detroit New York City Buffalo New York
shockingly Baltimore Chicago and then
our friend Portland rounding out the top
12 right there then you have the most
conservative cities you got nobody's
living in these cities Jackson
Mississippi The Woodlands Texas
uh some City in Idaho I can't even
pronounce Gainesville Georgia not even
Gainesville Florida Provo Utah Fort
Smith Arkansas Rapid City South Dakota
Clermont Florida I've never heard of it
and I lived in Florida my whole life
Great Falls Montana Greenville South
Carolina I'm just saying this yeah these
liberal cities as nonsensical as they
are their job is so much harder than
conservative cities because there's so
many more people in these cities so
here's a question you've got to ask
here's a question I gotta ask
and Adam hear me out on when I ask this
question for you
every major city did it start
conservative or did it start liberal
let me ask it one more time every great
country okay every great country every
great City every great state did it
start conservative or did it start
liberal
I would guess that it started a little
bit more conservative every great
company that was founded was it founded
by a capitalist or a socialist
capitalist capitalist okay
um New York city was it built by
socialists or capitalists capitalism
listen capitalists build and create
things socialists and liberals destroy
them
it's that simple so just because the
city is big now don't forget the people
that built the city
the credit isn't who's running it today
because what socialists are turned on by
the best example to give you a socialist
is the following you ready here's
socialist okay
you're you're in a world with a lot of
girls what happens if you bring a girl
that you know she's a gold digger who
will she find
she'll find the dude with money she'll
find to do with the money will she ever
do find the guy that dates the guy that
doesn't have the money uh this on Gold
Digger principles
[__] what you look like she's solving
for what the green gold is what she's
solving for right she saw him for
digging gold okay socialists are not
gonna go to those cities those cities
don't have money for them to dig
socialists go to big cities to dig gold
AOC may be the biggest gold digger
in all of America they're digging gold
let me go take all the money from the
people that built an incredible City
like New York and see if I can destroy
them and demonize them so every time you
give this argument about it is harder to
manage a liberal City no no no don't
feel sorry for these guys let's not get
sympathetic for Nancy Pelosi on how hard
our job is San Francisco was once an
incredible City
those bridges were not built by
socialists okay that City that
incredible all over the place you go to
when you look at is like I cannot even
believe a city like this exists how
beautiful it is right
a capitalist a conservative build that
City and then eventually a socialist
someone on the left came and destroys
the city that's how Cycles work
companies are founded and built by
capitalists they're destroyed by
socialist leaders within a company that
want to please everybody
company that's built at the beginning
stages of it they're built knowing
they're going to offend some people then
it's destroyed by annuity that comes in
that's afraid of offending the people
that are not growing the company rather
than being worried about the people that
have grown the company I did a video uh
uh yesterday with Kai and Brandon and
Kelly and Mike and we're sitting here
we're kind of going through it and you
know what this whole thing was about
here's what the videos was about
um
and right after this I want to go into
this articles I don't want to do this
without this and I got Max 7 call
I want you to think about Adam in your
life Vinnie yes Tom
who gets the best out of you
think about the people in your life that
got the best out of you who got the best
out of you
think about names I can give names who
got the best out of you in your life
who got the best at you can you think of
names give us some names yeah like my
mother okay my high school football high
school football coach give us his first
name uh Mike okay who else got the best
out of you Tom who got the best out of
you Gary and one hell my parents who
else got the best at you powerful who
else got the best brother who else gets
the best at you rob who gets the best
daddy in your life who got the best out
of you my father okay who else gets the
best out of you
in your life friends teachers coaches
colleagues who got the co-workers yeah
co-workers who gets the best out of you
driven bosses driven bosses who else
gets the best out of you
think about the names you're going to
place right now on who got the best at
you okay
now here's the thing you ready for the
flip side
this guy uh Trevor uh mawod who was the
coach mental coach for Russell Wilson
he met him in 2012. Trevor my what okay
when he met him he says you're going to
be great your mic's on Rob you're going
to be great because I'm going to make
you mentally great
for 12 years this guy in him not 12
years till he died they talked every
single day
Russell Wilson said there was not a day
that went by what I've been talking to
this guy and he wins a Super Bowl this
guy's mental coached 12 different first
round draft picks number one picks I
think I think it's 12 or 14. it's a big
number if you can find this five key
principles he follows five key
principles he follows
and he's going through all the stuff
that he's developing Russell Wilson wins
Russell Wilson just had his worst career
Worst season of his career last year
right he's been on a down slope you know
when this guy died 2021. what yeah
there's five things he talks about
number number one he talks about the uh
go neutral no matter what happens in
your life try to stay neutral stop
giving credence to feelings that's
exactly what they are they come and go
use what you have don't be like I'm not
as tall as that guy I'm not gonna use
what you got don't compare yourself
number four focus on reducing negativity
not increasing positivity and number
five watch your language on how you talk
to each other as a teammate okay stay on
number four so remember how I asked you
the question about who gets the best out
of you now watch this let me flip it on
you let me flip it on you
who do you know in your life that gets
the worst out of you
people
that somehow someway got the worst out
of you you had an idea it was a great
idea they always shut down the idea here
like I don't want to share ideas with
this guy okay
who got the worst out of you who always
compared you who always said why can't
you be like Mary's husband why can't you
be like such and such as boyfriend why
can't you be like such and such a son
who gets the worst Saturday same type of
people no not necessarily it's different
people so here's here's how life is
sometimes we think it's better to get
more of the people that get the best out
of us but what Trevor talks about
the battle is to eliminate the people
that get the worst at you it is more
effective to eliminate the people that
get worse out of you then to increase
the number of people that get the best
out of you yet still keep those people
that get the worst at you in your life
what's the moral of the story here hey
those people that get the best out of
the people in that City built these
incredible cities those people that get
the worst out of people destroy these
same cities so these same cities that
started off as capitalist conservatives
found what is conservative by the way
conservative means what it just means
fiscally responsible get to work be
responsible do your part Carry Your Own
Way take care of your family why are
your kids doing this Adam take care of
your kids Vinnie pay your bills man why
don't you do this why don't you do that
Patrick do your thing conservatives do
yourself accountable right it's
accountability that's how great
companies and great cities are born are
built and destroyed by the rest watch
this article by Wall Street Journal by
the way if we can pull this up these
stats are going to shock you America
pulls back from values that once defined
it okay this is a Wall Street Journal
norc poll finds okay a new Wall Street
Journal poll finds that American
priorities have helped Define the
national character for Generations such
as patriotism religion having children
and involvement in the community are
receding in important money is the only
priority that has grown in importance in
the past quarter Century younger
Americans in particular place law
importance on these values many of which
were Central to the lives of their
parents only 23 percent of adults under
age of 30 said that having children was
very important you got to see these
numbers show the show the charts that
you have take a look at this look at
this one here really
percent who say that these values are
very important to them patriotism 1998
70 that's only 25 years ago today 38
percent
religion was 62 percent
39 who is talking about God having
children was 59 double 25 years ago it's
30. people don't want to have kids today
Community involvement went from 47 to 62
down to 27. money went from 31 to 41 to
43.
if you go a little lower look at these
other numbers that it has with religion
if you keep going Lord there's a few
other charts uh okay zoom in on this one
here so we can see so zoom in so we can
read what it says at the top as well
zoom out a little bit a little bit more
go a little lower so you can have there
you go percent who say these values are
very important to them personally shown
amongst the youngest and oldest age
groups patriotism
36 percent
having children age group look at the
age group religion hard work go to the
Bottom now hard work the only people
that believe in that is what above 62
years old okay go go lower there's
another chart that they have I believe
that talks about you know uh uh read the
the people who say these values are very
important to them Democrats look at
patriotism wow Independence look at
Republicans 59 percent Republicans are
more Patriot by 36 percent this is Wall
Street Journal talking religion
Democrats 27 Republicans 2x having
children 26 20 38 Community involvement
32-23 Democrats have the highest one
without Community involvement money
Democrats and Republicans are tied for
money it's the one area they agree with
for each of the following has our
society gone too far to not gone far
enough or is it about right shown by
percentage who say too far Democrats
accepting people who are transgender
okay look at that
point spread look at the spread there
Adam I don't know if you're looking at
it yeah 15 Dems versus 75 Republicans
schools and universities taking steps to
promote racial and ethnic diversity six
percent to 50. look at the look how
wider the wings how much we have divided
accepting people who are gay lesbian and
bisexual seven 31 is the people that are
in the middle reasonable ones look at
Democrats and independents what 731.52
businesses taking steps to promote
racial ethnicity
729.52 promoting equality between men
and women two percent but you would
think Democrats were doing it that's
weird no no it's it's the opposite of
what you're thinking yeah it's the
opposite of what you're thinking so when
you look at data like this what do you
think about time when you see this
we're in a divided America number one is
what I think and number two and I may
not win any friends on this but I got to
be part of carrying the mantle because
the values that made America great in
that built America still are necessary
we need people that are unapologetically
capitalists and entrepreneurs to build
the jobs and the tools and Industry of
tomorrow we need that and along the way
we need to be you know what you know
we need to be neighborly and we need to
serve in our communities and you look at
this someone has to carry the mantle for
the things that truly built wonderful
communities and companies here's my
question to all of you Tom and YouTube
and Adam what what what what made this
shift what from all what was like that
was 25 years Pat what something's
happening Tom where all those values all
the community all the you know doing
being held accountable it's shifted I've
been I've I may have an opinion on this
what do you think I I think we've
you know you can go back and look at
just the last
look it was 25-year spread right and
just look at the the last 16 years of uh
presidents and and see what's happened
uh we've been I think in many ways it's
each person's responsibility for where
they are and what they say and what they
do but I I think we've been led into
um Discord and we've been Led You Know
by our leadership and the way political
campaigns come out
and we've been led into this this Great
Divide well let's go to 98 so who was
president 98 was it Clinton okay
so Clinton goes to Bush goes to go back
to the polls again if you can show it go
back to the polls again
uh uh go back to the polls okay so check
this out check this out seven from 1998
to 2019 is how long 19 years yeah from
19 2019 to 2023 is the big drop off okay
look at the drop off here and which
sector if patriotism if you look at
patriotism from 70 to 61 that's 19 years
so meaning we had a drop off after
Clinton after Bush after Obama at 100 we
had a drop off okay
but from Trump to Biden this is the
lowest we've ever had look at the
patriotism on how low it is in America
today religion from 62 to 48 it's a big
drop off 62 to 48 to 39. go to the next
one having
um
children 59 that's a massive drop off of
16 points so the credit for that goes to
uh Bush and Obama 59-43 now 30.
Community involvement 47 to 62 to 27.
may I is the 62 2019 2019. so you lock
us all up inside do you federally tell
us we have to get inside and we can't
work and can't help with each other and
this happens yep I'm so surprised yeah
weird so but but the moral of the story
here is these are these are values and
principles of what others think about
America okay these are basic values and
America for me the biggest Factor Tom if
you ask me is the following I was at the
uh church this week and it's a big
church here in Fort Lauderdale so I was
there in people pulled up and they come
and they talk and we have great
conversations together you know what the
biggest thing was how many people would
say Patrick you're a Christian I thought
you were a Jew really I said so really
so yeah no this entire time I've been
following your content I thought you
were judging well South Florida bet
David yeah
Joseph I thought you were just no I'm a
Christian so now I'm so happy you come
into a church like this Etc yeah it's
great I said you know one of the biggest
things right now that
um
I can't you know people sit there oh let
me tell you this person won because of
that and that person because I don't
know why other people want I can tell
you what I want
at 44 years old today I had a uh
something interesting happened to me
this weekend not good tough but
something happened this weekend to me
okay and it's not it's not a big deal
it's not something I want anybody to
worry about health or anything like that
but it's something that it was it was
annoying what happened this weekend
and
I'm sitting there talking to Jen and
we're talking we're going back and for
having a great conversation together and
I said you know
what this makes me realize I can't
understand people who are willing to
risk life living without God
I I can't understand that life
because to live a life without God you
think you know it all I don't think I
know it all to live like with life
without God you think you can do it all
on your own I can't do it all on my own
to live life without God is saying you
have all the answers I don't have all
the answers
I need help in raising of my kids with
good people around me as well because I
only have certain amount of hours with
them every day they go to school to live
a life today without God man upstairs
prayer a community you're a part of if
there's ever been a time in our lifetime
at least you know in the last however
many years to risk living life without
God this is by far the worst season to
do that I agree take any risk you want
to take do not take the risks today of
living without God okay and by the way
this isn't the debate we can have the
debate conversation no problem we can
have the uh uh debate conversation of
Christianity or you know seven day or
LDS or Jew or you know Muslim or you
know Buddha we can have that debate no
problem okay
but I'm telling you right now the debate
you don't want to have is living life
without believing there is a God and you
end up being wrong and there isn't which
there is a risk but the risk of living
life saying there's not a God and then
all of a sudden there is
and you know you could have a source to
help you through some of the times that
you are by yourself if kids know today
listen mommy's not going to be there
that is not going to be there but if
you're ever alone God's there with you
what do you think that does to a kid
think about a kid today that's like
nobody's there with me and my dad's not
here my mom's not here
but you know what God I think you're
there because I was told you're there
whether it's true or not what is that
kid going to go through during that
season we all go through certain Seasons
we can all look nice and Polished today
man think about the season that you were
not polished how did you make it through
that what if you did something stupid
during that time we don't know about
your story many of us could have done
something stupid to not be here right
now so what this validates to me when
you look at these types of numbers is
division is the lack of love for America
when I talk about how great of a country
America the concepts that it was founded
on I can't tell you how many people say
you know I can't believe you're saying
that and all this other stuff man I'm
I'm a patriot and I'm from Iran and I
love what America was founded on
what America was founded on I love what
America was founded on it changed my
life an average regular guy like me
there's nothing special about me trust
me don't let me fool you there's nothing
special about this guy regular guy I was
High School Junior High School you will
never find a report card that you can
say bingo
figure this guy out he was very smart he
was the captain of the football team
nothing never played organized Sports
never had any kind of 2.8 3.0 GP I don't
even know what the what is the class you
take that's above the other stuff I've
never taken an honors I've never taken
any of that stuff you know you talk
magnet stuff like that we were more
repellents more than Magnus we were not
the kids that you would sit there and
said these guys are going to do anything
this guy went to the Army thinking my
plan was 20 years and I was going to
retire six years ago nobody would have
known me I told that on this the other
day on the importance of God
so you realize if God wasn't in my life
you and I would have never met wow I
said can you imagine if you and I never
meet how cool is it that we know each
other God did that for your son I told
this to Dylan and he looks at it he
probably was like what you don't even
know what that look to each other was
like
the hog man it's like man I'm so glad we
met I can't imagine living life without
ever meeting Dylan my God is so freaking
good to us sometimes we got to take a
moment
uh we got to take a moment and just be
grateful and take us back to uh uh not
solving for Perfection not solving for
any of that stuff solving for why this
place has 40 plus million people of
immigrants that chose to come here and
our family our parents our grandparents
didn't say let's go to Russia didn't say
let's go to Iran didn't say let's go to
China didn't say let's go to Cuba didn't
say let's go to Venezuela but they said
let's go to America there's a reason for
that and we have to fight for it we have
to sell it we have to explain it and we
have to encourage others to buy into it
my Tico yesterday finished at the Shrek
he finished on Saturday in six days it's
1069 page book somebody commented on the
bottom and she said I can't believe you
had that's torture for a kid to make him
read us so first of all the kid wasn't
required to read it he did it by himself
but I said I said I said I if if it's up
to me I'm going to read you exactly what
I told this lady
I said if I have to choose between me
brainwashing my kid into thinking for
himself or allowing Society to brainwash
him to think he's a victim I'm gonna do
my part I'm gonna do my part so anyways
what a podcast man that article really
got to me when I saw this article here I
think everybody needs to go read that
article and Talk Amongst your family and
your friends and your peers anyways good
podcast today
um yes Tom and by the way we're all
about education we're all about the open
debate and we're all about edifying
entrepreneurs right and
we've got an event that's coming that's
part of value treatment that's important
what is this oh we got SLS coming up
sales leadership seminar we do this once
a year it is going to be April I think
24th at the Boca Resort it's limited to
only 250 people uh uh I wanna this is
the one that uh it's you have to you
have to have a minimum of a million
dollars of top line revenue and netting
a quarter million to qualify for it if
that's you uh you can uh you can uh put
a link below to the event to to have
somebody get a hold of them if you can
do that SLS put that link in the
description but you have to have a top
line revenue of a million dollars
netting a quarter million leading five
sales people if that's you this will be
a very good conference for you it's
myself and it's very intense it's very
direct it's not for everybody but if
you're somebody that qualifies for this
I highly recommend you come spend these
two days with us at the Boca Resort so
and I'm Tom has it his podcast Adam has
his podcast I tomorrow I'm starting my
Vince show which is like variety comedy
it's just I don't even want to call it a
podcast Pat it's going to be something I
hear what a couple of our new guys that
I had lunch with the other day that I'm
excited about something new stars it's
gonna be it's gonna be fun yeah it's
going to be interesting I'm going to be
using it helps people it's gonna be good
it's a break from the seriousness I love
it awesome okay guys have a good one hey
are we doing a podcast this week on
Thursday Rob
I guess I believe so okay sounds good
we'll do it again this Thursday podcast
take everybody bye bye